永远要记住姑娘，
你现在已经成年了，
你22岁了，
权力的天平已经开始发生转移了，
你要做那个做决策的人，
钱在你的手里，
将来你爸爸生病了需要花钱，
你才有决策权，
钱如果在他们的手里，
那都不叫你孝顺。
我是03年的，
我男朋友也是03年的，
我们是在大学的时候认识在一起的，
毕业之后我就跟着他，
在他家这边和他父亲一起做电商。
今年我们两边家长见面了嘛，
准备今年年底订婚，
明年结婚，
商量彩礼之类的事情，
他爸妈说的是给20万的彩礼，
我们现在还没有订婚，
但是他爸爸妈妈出钱买了一辆20万的车，
也写在我的名下。
我自己的原生家庭比较复杂，
在小的时候我的父母就离异了，
我跟着我的爸爸，
我是有个后妈，
我们结婚的话，
我爸爸他就是说不给我准备陪嫁，
南康父母不是说给20万的彩礼吗？
我的爸爸最开始他们商量的时候就是说让我拿3万回去给他们办酒席，
剩下的钱都给我自己拿着，
年底准备快要订婚了，
结果他们突然改口了，
说要8万块钱，
我不知道这个钱我应不应该给，
因为他们一分钱的陪嫁也不给我还要把彩礼那么多，
我不知道该怎么做，
我问一下你后妈和你爸是不是又生个小孩？
儿啊，
没有生小孩，
但是我后妈带管来有个小儿子，
那你爸在从小的生活过程当中对你有格外的偏爱吗？
我爸对我其实挺好的，
我从小到大我身上也都没有缺过钱花，
他给我钱给的也都挺多的，
我之前想学艺术，
他也让我去学了，
我在学校的时候挺好的，
但是我感觉毕业了之后对我没有那么好了。
你爸只有你这一个亲生的孩子，
是不是？
我爸有两个，
还有一个妹妹是跟在我妈妈，
但是基本上算是没有联系吧？
那你爸和你后妈之间谁挣钱多呀？
我爸挣个钱多，
你爸大概一年挣多少钱呀？
我爸挣不了多少钱，
他就是在工地上上班的那种，
一年可能也就只能挣几万20的样子吧。
那你爸和你后妈之间，
他俩是谁掌管家庭经济啊？
我爸跟我那个后妈之前最开始在一起的时候就是出去上班，
他们两个会一起，
这些年就是我后妈在家里面，
我爸一个人出去上班，
就相当于可能是一个主内一个主外这种，
那后妈小的时候对你好吗？
我后妈是我在高中的时候他们才在一起的，
我接触的其实也很少，
就只有我放假回家或者是过年的时候才会接触一下，
那如果是这样的话，
如果我是你的话，
我就是说这个钱也想给你爸爸，
让人家男方。
不同意，
男方觉得这20万的话，
就应该是到时候要贡献到小家庭的，
到时候我要怀孕生孩子是要用到，
就月子中心啊这些男方是不同意的，
就这么说，
男方父母并没有说其他的什么，
他们说这20万反正给我的，
看我自己说拿多少，
他们没有赢面，
说什么，
反正就是这个意思，
这样说的啊，
反正咱给一个借口，
给一个台阶下，
本质的目的就是拿到，
我不想给钱的目的就是说在你爸爸那个家愿意办酒席你就办，
不愿意办酒席我也不强求，
但这20万的钱必须得放我手里。
最开始的时候我跟我男朋友是商量的，
给5万，
结果后面我跟我一个好朋友小时候我爸爸把我放在亲戚家，
我亲戚家对我也不好，
我就经常去我那个朋友家，
后来认了他爸爸妈妈当干妈的那种，
过年都会走动，
所以时候我那个朋友大家都知道，
然后那天我爸就给我那个朋友打电话，
然后他劝我把彩礼拿出来些，
我那个后妈就在旁边说，
如果我不把彩礼钱拿出来的话，
就让我就这样待在男方家里，
谁怕谁呀，
我现在20大几的人了，
我现在自己又能挣钱了，
你知道我待在男方家里，
男道对我是一种怎么了，
是一种制裁吗？
谁怕谁啊，
我怕什么呢，
对不对？
我跟你说，
姐妹们啊，
听好了啊，
第一，
她本就是个后妈，
第二，
她小的时候也没怎么带过你，
没怎么养育过你，
第三，
她撺掇你爸问你要。
8万块钱，
你以为这8万块钱会轮到你爸花吗？
能不能够到最后，
可能是花给他两个儿子，
我凭啥呀？
我把我自己卖了，
卖8万块钱还给你一个后妈，
花给你的儿子，
我是不是有毛病啊？
我这么干我分不清亲疏远近了吗？
我跟谁最亲？
跟我自己最亲？
钱放在哪里我最放心？
放在我自己手里最放心。
理解这个逻辑了哈，
你永远要记住姑娘，
你现在已经成年了，
你22岁了，
权力的天平已经开始发生转移了，
你要做那个做决策的人，
钱在你的手里，
将来你爸爸生病了，
需要花钱，
你才有决策权，
钱如果在他们的手里，
那都不叫你孝顺。
理解了吧，
我今天此时此刻，
我坚持我自己，
钱在我的手里，
我可以用来发展我的小家庭，
我可以用来发展我的事业，
我可以用来学本领，
我可以用来投资做培训，
我可以用来提升我的社会价值，
只有我自己足够有钱了，
将来才有可能说我爸生病了，
我爸需要钱了，
我爸享时候对我好，
我才有可能帮到我爸。
否则的话，
你现在把8万块钱给到你爸妈，
钱一定是在你后妈手上的，
起到什么作用，
到时候你爸生病了，
不还得找你？
他们说那个话的意思就是，
如果我不拿钱的话，
他们就会跟我闹掰的那种，
如果一个大老爷们儿自己的主都做不了，
得听一个后老伴儿的话，
闹掰了怕什么，
你怕什么？
如果一个大老爷们。
到他这种份上的话，
闹掰了，
你怕什么？
好，
那我就一分钱都不给他，
就这么干啊，
你怕什么？
你现在已经22岁了，
如果你能第一保护好自己的钱，
第二对钱大大方方的，
不要害怕别人说你怎么样的啊，
只有当你有一天足够强大了，
你才能够回报那些曾经对你好的人，
包括你爸，
你爸是小的时候对你好，
但是你爸现在就是个怂货，
你听他的干什么？
听我的，
因为订婚结婚按自己的节奏，
自己做自己人生的主，
你想在哪里，
你想怎么办，
你想要在哪里弄就在哪里弄。
如果你爸和你的后妈威胁你，
说不给你办酒席，
正好我不办了，
你能把我怎么着呢？
我不办了，
我就在南方办，
不可以吗？
好，
有什么大不了，
但是你一定要有主见，
即便你嫁到南方了，
我来不是来受委屈的，
我来不是看着你们将来怎么对我的，
我来是要创建一个家庭的，
我是要来打江山的，
我来就是什么事情我该争取的我就争取，
比如说这20万的彩礼钱，
我争取的我就一定要存到我自己的卡里，
以后你们谁也别想动这笔钱，
别管是亲爹也好，
亲妈也好，
老公也好，
公公也好，
婆婆也好，
你一定要有这种杀气和霸气，
你才能把日子过好，
知道吧，
还是要讲道理，
如果说你现在跟着公公创业，
你做电商，
你就给我认真钻研，
什么苦活累活，
接待的活，
什么跟外界联系的活，
你都。
干都抢着干，
为什么？
干出来的才是你自己的社会资源，
联系出来的才是你自己的社会力量。
亲兄弟，
明算账，
我干这个岗位，
我该分多少钱我就拿我该拿的，
不要怕跟什么老公公谈钱，
好像觉得我做儿媳妇儿的是不是就不乖巧了？
乖求顶屁用，
我要的是实力，
我要的是我干了什么活，
我拿什么钱在这儿干，
干的顺心我就干在这儿干，
干的不顺心老不单干，
要的是这个，
明白了啊，
就这样啊啊，
拜拜，
我今天可能情绪有点不对啊，
大家多多包涵，
想不到有一个姑娘本来就是历史老师，
非常善良，
非常受学生的爱戴的一个历史老师，
所以原生家庭爸妈逼着他结婚，
就因为这么一件事儿，
所以我今天情绪有点不对，
乖乖女就是这么悲哀，
她是乖呀，
是听话了，
可是她听话的代价就是他没有办法过自己心的那一关。
记得点赞关注哦。